should you start a for-profit or
nonprofit business
I love businesses that have a social
angle right you should want to give back
to your community the people around you
and make the world a better place not
just through the product or service that
you provide but also just by being a
company that wants to do good and find
ways to do that if it's donations if
it's supporting through time whatever it
is I believe that it's a lot easier to
have a bigger impact if you have money
coming in so many nonprofits that
startup struggle because they don't have
cash they have no money so they have a
great they have a great vision for what
they want to do they have a noble
purpose but they're constantly
struggling and dying trying to find
funds to make their business their
organization happen you're constantly
underfunded and so I lean towards the
for-profit side because by running a
successful business you have money
coming in that you can then give back to
whatever project you want you don't need
as much outside funding because you're
making money and making money and
helping people are not mutually
exclusive
making a lot of money doesn't mean that
you are not giving money back
in fact they completely support each
other I got a question from one of my
facebook readers love you guys
rajae who wrote in to say he has a
problem in that he's 18 years old he's
seen my videos he wants to start a
non-profit or profit is not sure which
one to do he has a dream that helped
children in a lot of different ways he's
thinking he wants to do a for-profit
business but he doesn't have a business
idea to start because what he really
wants to do is start a non-profit you
got to follow your passion okay if you
don't have a business idea if you're not
wired for business then you can't start
a business you're not gonna have success
you're not gonna be happy because what
you really want to do is do the charity
if you're on the fence if you're not
sure if you have business ideas and and
you don't think that you can marry that
with a successful charity
then then that makes sense because you
can that's just a limiting belief but if
you have no interest in business and
you're struggling just to find a product
that will work then don't go into
business you have to go in it for the
right reason you have to go in it
because you believe in that product or
service that you're selling so do the
charity what may help you is find a
business partner someone who who is
running the business and you could be
their charity arm so it's finding ways
that you get cash flow because if you're
not running the company you have to rely
on outside people to give you money but
you'll still have more success at that
because you love the charity part of it
then you will try to force a solution
into being a business owner it's harder
but you can still have success you'll
have the most success by doing what
you're passionate about this is like
being you know being a banker being a
bowler okay the common advice would be
go be a banker you can make tons of
money being a banker you're good at
being a banker you went to school for
being a banker be a banker but you love
bowling people will tell you you can't
make money as a bowler what are you
doing a bowling are you kidding me but
if your passion is not in banking and
it's in bowling if you keep going down
the banking career path you're gonna be
stuck you're gonna always feel like
there's something missing in your life
because you're not doing something that
your passion but you may be good at it
but you're not passionate about it
you're doing it for the wrong reasons
you're doing it for just the security
and the safety and maybe external you
know satisfaction of people support you
that's what society tells you to do
you're believing in that more than
you're believing in yourself you should
go be a bowler
and if you are super passionate about
bowling you'll make money and more money
than you would being a banker I believe
that and I've seen it happen over and
over and over and over and over again
just because society tells you this is
what you have to do if you go out and do
it and you're not excited about it
you're not gonna have massive success
and you'll always feel that something's
missing in your life so for you don't
force the business do the charity you'll
have more success believe those are you
watching you liked the video please give
a thumbs up below subscribe to the
channel to see more leave a comment if
you have a question or you want to say
something about this video
I love Tino's come in every morning I
read my comments the best part of my day
so thank you so much and I'll see you
soon